you were a rapper for a short period of
time right yeah I was rapping for like
the first half of my life and then and
it just was it didn't work yeah well
this is good you found what you found
what happened for you that's and then
with that with comedy I get to rap again
so that's that's that's did you what it
were your rap names did you have more
than one oh it has so many I was very
indecisive person but so I got my first
one because I started it I was like
trolling people on AOL chats I don't
know if you kids know what that is but
this is this is back in the day yeah
yeah we had these battle chat rooms
right where people who would like and
this is on dial-up so people who would
be writing lyrics in waiting to see what
somebody would say and it was hilarious
to make fun of them that got sucked in
and I started battling these people so
my name was spitting flames yeah it was
it was derived from dragged on from
Rough Riders and he thought we talked
about like I'm spitting flames on my
dragon you know so I was like yeah me
too for some reason and then I changed
it pretty quick because it was stupid
and I and I changed to Callisto and that
sounded dope Callisto started stuff yeah
but then I got in a Greek mythology and
I realized that was a goddess and I was
like why don't for that pretty then I
changed it to John Doe cuz it's like
it's like infamous for rappers be like
you don't know me if I'm John Doe you
definitely don't yeah
but then people really didn't so I've
got you know self-conscious about that
and I changed it to Johnny dollar and
because you know why not yeah and then I
changed it to chief dollar because I
couldn't drop the dollar right then I
went to a strip club and drop the dollar
and I was like oh that's fun so I did
drop the dollar and it just went with
chief all the way around and in that
that was like the last name but now my
comedy rap name is big Nick as in big
nipples big nipples I got I got I got
big nipple yeah
I don't want to think about that yeah
well now you think about a tune I got
two nice soup back to here
you